er schwadroniert von kokain preisen und
von drogenhandel in den politiker
familien verstrickt sind und millionen
schauen gebannt dabei zu er redet über
vergewaltigungsopfer die später
umgebracht wurden und über morde an
journalisten
er gesteht selbst schlägertrupps in
zeitungsredaktionen geschickt zu haben
und er genießt seine auftritte hat
picker mehrfach verurteilter
untergetauchter mafiaboss rühmt sich
politiker mit seinem geld groß gemacht
zu haben und er behauptet sie auch
wieder vernichten zu können seit wochen
zelebriert er aus seinem exil einen
rachefeldzug gegen teile der regierenden
partei von präsident erdogan und vor
allem gegen dessen innenminister
schünemann cdu von dem er sich betrogen
und abserviert fühlt du wirst vor den
obersten gerichtshof gestellt du hast
keine chance
ich werde auspacken und ich habe die
beweise ich mach dich fertig soldo steht
unter druck
er soll sich im amt bereichert soll
freunde vorstrafe ermittlungen geschützt
haben behauptet pk
der innenminister muss sich vor
laufenden kameras gegen die
anschuldigungen eines mafioso
verteidigen
es ist ein polit skandal erster güte und
auch andere müssen sich erklären wie
ex-ministerpräsident wilderen dessen
sohn so behauptet pk organisiere den
drogenschmuggel aus südamerika in die
türkei präsident erdogan lässt das
spektakel lange unkommentiert nach
wochen erst stellte er sich hinter
seinen innenminister bezeichnet pk als
vom ausland gesteuerten agentin olivia
behagt jemandem der friede und die
sicherheit in unserem land nicht
wir stehen zu unserem innenminister in
seinem kampf gegen kriminelle banden und
terroristen
und wir werden das auch weiter
[Musik]
nach umfragen aber glaubt eine mehrheit
in der türkei dass an den vorwürfen des
mafia bosses etwas dran ist wie
millionen andere im land verfolgt auch
vedat die pk videos wie eine krimiserie
eine serie die rätsel aufgibt
peter platziert im bild gegenstände
symbole die botschaften senden wo die
seine fangemeinde begeistert
entschlüsselt die kiste da das könnte
die büchse der pandora
denn in seinem vorherigen video rief er
dass er die büchse der pandora geöffnet
habe und das fernglas bedeutet ich weiß
was ihr vorhaben denn in einem anderen
video meinte er meine leute sind überall
ich bekomme alle informationen ich sehe
alles die wahrscheinlichkeit dass er die
wahrheit sagt ist groß weil niemand
nachforscht es wird keine
untersuchungskommission gegründet kein
staatsanwalt ermittelt gerade deshalb
glaube ich an das was er sagt auch jan
dinter glaubt daran
der bekannte journalist floh vor der
türkischen justiz nach deutschland in
berlin zeigt er in einer kunstaktion die
zelle in die man ihn damals steckte weil
er von waffenlieferungen der türkischen
regierung an islamisten in nordsyrien
berichtete peter behauptet nun in einem
seiner videos er selbst habe damals
diese lieferungen im auftrag der
regierung organisiert er hat damals für
die regierung gearbeitet
es ist wichtig dass jemand der die
geschichte von innen kenne mein bericht
bestätigt er ist jetzt ein informant ein
zeuge
deshalb sollte mein fall endlich fallen
gelassen werden die videos sagt jan dünn
da sinnvoller hinweise hinweise auf
vorgänge die nicht nur journalisten
sondern auch staatsanwälte beschäftigen
sollten
[Musik]
wir erfahren dank seiner videos dass der
innenminister einen kriminellen geholfen
hat das land zu verlassen bevor er
verhaftet werden sollte
das ist keine regierung mehr sondern
eine gangsterbande
die enge verbindung einiger politiker
zum organisierten verbrechen ist in der
türkei kein geheimnis
der mehrfach verurteilte mafia pate
aladin cakici ist prominentes mitglied
der rechtsextremen grauen wölfe der
gewaltbereite arm der ultra
nationalistischen partei mhp die mhp
wiederum ist präsident erdogan
politischer bündnispartner und der chef
dieses bündnispartners holte einen
killer den er als seinen persönlichen
freund bezeichnet kurzerhand aus dem
knast ist ein mafia boss der seine
eigene frau vor den augen seiner tochter
ermordet hat so jemanden aus dem
gefängnis zu holen ist ein zeichen an
die wähler
schaut wie mächtig wir sind erdogans akp
fakt ihre mit vielen zweifelhaften
leuten um an der macht zu bleiben
dadurch gerate die partei nun selbst in
die krise meint der soziologe ahmed
kasse man die partei die einst
korruption und vetternwirtschaft
bekämpfen wollte sei nun selbst
verstrickten affären und skandale nach
19 jahren wird die regierungspartei
ihrem eigenen anspruch nicht mehr
gerecht mit dem sie mal angetreten war
und sie haben probleme sich das selbst
einzugestehen
mehr als die hälfte der wähler ist
überzeugt dass etwas falsch läuft in
diesem land auch wenn sie nicht alle
vorwürfe in den videos glauben handfeste
beweise für seine gangster geschichten
hat pk noch nicht geliefert trotzdem so
glaubt am dünn da werde man versuchen
ihn zum schweigen zu bringen
[Musik]
ich denke es läuft gerade einen handel
ab tk verhandelt mit der regierung und
von diesen verhandlungen wird es
abhängen wie viel erdogan bereit ist zu
zahlen damit pk aufhört zu reden
[Musik]
noch aber redet peter weiter und hat für
kommende woche weitere enthüllungen
angekündigt dann will er über recep
tayyip erdogan selbst sprechen ganz
vertraut wie er sagt von bruder zu
bruder